Speaker 1: Remember anybody who wants to
participate. Name and location as your
nickname. If you have only one or the other. I
will be unable to call on you. Let's go next to
Noah from New York. Noah from New York, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hey, David. Good to talk to you. I've
been watching you for a while, so a little
nervous, but thank you for bringing me on.
Speaker 1: Well, so far, you're
doing great. Your audio's good.
So we're off to a good start. Really?
Speaker 5: Thank you. I had to. I had to
really look around the settings to figure out how
to turn off the discordant notifications. Good.
And now I would say I got a question for you. It's
just a little more of a silly question. It's not
too serious because we can't really know. It's
like, you know, what would you do in a zombie
apocalypse type stuff? Right. I'm just curious.
I want to take this back and forth with you. How
do you think what's happening is climate change
is going to pan out? We're not going to clearly
avoid it. We're not doing nearly enough. What do
you think the end result of all this is going to
be? I mean, the damage what's what's going to
happen, how it's going to affect our dialog
and politics moving forward? What do you.
Speaker 1: Think? It's so difficult to say
and we're so terrible at predicting things.
So let me give you one claim that's made and
then I and which I don't believe, and then we'll
back up from it. There are some who say, listen,
I don't deny that what climatologists have
identified is real and it's coming. I just
am confident that science and engineering is
going to be able to keep up to prevent it from
ever really getting that bad. Okay. That's
something some people say, I don't subscribe
to that. I don't subscribe to that. However, I
do think that after there is a bunch of damage
done by climate change and we're already starting
to see it, we see pollution deaths, we see sea
level rising and certain places increasingly
underwater like we're already seeing it. But
I think after there is some significant damage
from climate change, I think then much of the
world will kick it into high gear. And yes, it'll
be too little, too late, but it will speed up to a
degree that then we can say now we're making some
progress, but it'll be after a bunch of damage is
done. That that's my genuine prediction. Like
once things really actually start to get bad.
Speaker 5: Yeah. That's what I thought, too.
Is that like you're not really going to see it
taken seriously until you get issues with like
climate refugees and mass migration to a lot of,
you know, what we call first
world countries or damage there.
Speaker 1: And the thing is, a lot of people are
going to hear our conversation, Noah, and they'll
say, but guys, that's already happening. And I
don't deny that. But I'm saying it's going to
have to be more. It's going to have to be more.
Speaker 5: Yeah. It's going to be massive. Yeah,
I think. Do you think you're going to see, like
almost some crackdowns on, like, those who have
opposed or do oppose it? And and generally, do
you think like like I'm talking like authoritarian
situation because I do wonder this like if things
get very bad and desperate, are you going to see
like hard line measures taken by governments
that are going to cause like push back and stuff?
Speaker 1: Absolutely. There are countries that
already lean more authoritarian. The countries
that lean more authoritarian. Whenever we get
to this imaginary point that I'm talking about,
I think you will see some very hardline
action by some governments. But we'll have
to wait and see exactly what governments,
which governments those are at that time.
Speaker 5: Yeah. And how that
will go. And one last thing.
Do you think people who are like hardcore denying
it are ever going to come around? Or do you think
there's probably still going to be like a block
that are just going to convince themselves
that it's like Antifa changing the weather?
Speaker 1: Yeah. There will always be people
who who believe it's geo engineering or something
like that. All right, listen, before I let you go,
can you off the off the top of your head, can you
name four countries that start with the letter L.
Speaker 4: What say.
Speaker 5: Lithuania? Man,
you're putting me on the spot here. So
now it's like. It's like when people are
asked to name a book. Yeah, they're like,
name any book and they're like, Oh, God,
which. But there's so many. I mean.
Speaker 1: Lithuania is a big star.
Speaker 2: Sign.
Speaker 1: Liechtenstein. Yep, yep. I would
have also accepted Luxembourg, Latvia and Laos.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Here we go. Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: That's all right, Noah.
Thank you for the call. Appreciate it.
Speaker 4: You too.
Speaker 1: Take care. Take care.
There's Noah from New York, bringing up some sad
but relevant and important issues, I have to say.